all right guys
bang bang i've got amanda here thank you
so much for doing this yeah thanks for
having me all right let's just get
started what the hell is cbd
you started a company and there's cbd
gummies
i don't know what that is so what
exactly is cbd okay cannabis
cannabinoids you know what cannabis is
most people think of thc
right thc gets you psycho the
psychoactives gets you high
cbd is a component of that and if you
grow
up hemp plant it can turn into high thc
which would make it marijuana if you
harvest it before it hits that point
it's cbd all right you lost me this is
like science stuff
yeah uh when i think of weed
uh as somebody once told me if you say
marijuana on the internet that means
you're a cop
so weed
[Laughter]
weed is made up of thc and cbd exactly
okay so if it has high thc low cbd
it's weed marijuana all right if it's no
marijuana that's a cop
if it's low thc high cbd it's hemp
got it okay and then uh what you put
into the gummies is hemp derived
temp drive cbd and then you mix it with
other things we'll get to what those
are uh but the idea is cbd has what
impact on the body versus thc
so we have an ecs an endocannabinoid
system
okay which was just discovered in the
90s we didn't even know that we had this
and it helps regulate a lot of different
things right
um and so cbd is a really cool adaptogen
meaning it will help if you're over
stimulated or under-stimulated it will
adapt to that
okay so if i'm overstimulated it'll
bring me back down to kind of the
the regression to the mean exactly if
i'm under stimulated same thing i'll
bring you back okay
exactly and so we mix it with active
ingredients like you were just saying so
because cbdx is a really powerful
carrier and heightens the effects of the
active ingredients
so for example melatonin people take
melatonin we've mixed it with
really good quality full spectrum cbd
full spectrum means it has all the
terpenes in it
of the plant so it actually has what we
call the entourage effect it actually
helps
with efficacy so i eat a gummy
yes that gummy basically there's like
two different
compounds that team up the cbd is like
hey we're coming
and then we're going to bring the
melatonin i get on my back i'm carrying
the squad we're going
perfect and then the melatonin gets
there faster better
et cetera higher potency efficacy okay
potency i like that
that's like a wizard word potency all
right so there's higher potency
and that means that if i was going to
take melatonin versus if i take it via
the
sleep gummy that you have uh i will
actually get a better
effect from or or a more um kind of
broader effect
from the cbd enabled melatonin versus
just without it
yeah another example is the sex gummy
okay okay so the cbd helps calm your
brain
okay helps to a woman get in the mood
right because that's usually the hardest
part is like
turning your brain off to get in the
mood okay and then we didn't turn your
brain off
so you're not thinking about your
freaking to-do list got it okay and
you can actually like get in touch with
your body yep um and then the active
ingredients then start to
kick in and helps with like lubrication
stimulation etc okay and so again the
cbd kind of leads
got it helps calm the brain helps with
calm focus et cetera and then the active
ingredients heightened that as well
got it it's like active ingredients jump
on my back we're going all right so you
have a sex one you have
a sleep one stress stress what's that
one
it has l-theanine which is an amino acid
that helps with focus i know what that
is
okay all right um and so the whole idea
here is
i can take let's say the sex one if i'm
going to sleep or want to have sex
if i want to go to sleep i take the
sleep one um and if i want
if i feel stressed i could take the
stress one yep yep
can i take multiple ones in the same day
yeah okay can you die from cbd
no okay really yes
all right that seems you you would have
to take an immense amount
and like they don't even you can google
it it's really hard to find an accurate
answer of how much
and you would never from our products
like they're
it's smaller doses got it so like you
you would literally have to like inject
it into your veins and like for days
yeah and then maybe only maybe exactly
okay so
do people take like in the morning i
feel stressed let me take this
oh now i want to have sex let me take
the sex one and now i want to go to
sleep let me take the sleepover yeah
100 yeah and that's what we're focused
on is routines
and intentionality throughout your day
and that's why
i mean the cbd landscape the reason i
started is because it's so fragmented
and really confusing like all the
questions you're asking are like
scientific and rooted in like
understanding what a can of anointing
i'm a scientist
right exactly um and in your spare time
and so when i looked at the landscape
like i'm a single mom i have three kids
i was an executive at a company
i didn't have time to understand what
products were out there i wanted to know
like
i am not sleeping well what's going to
help me i am
having anxiety attacks during the day
like what's going to help me and so
we're a function first
formula we talk about what's the end
outcome versus just
trying to teach everybody the components
of a hemp plant
you want to sleep take the sleep exactly
right okay got it
uh when you think about this
there's all kinds of issues right so
most people right now like this is about
the point where they're like all right
he said some funny jokes she has
these products what the hell is she
doing talking about cbd gummies
on a podcast usually talks about bitcoin
one of the things that the cbd industry
shares with bitcoin and crypto companies
is
all of the legacy infrastructure they
don't they really haven't made up their
mind yet they don't really like it so
much and they can't outright just say
like you guys are bad people because
they're not
uh instead they just make it really hard
to do business the infrastructure uh
becomes difficult maybe talk through
like the technology stack that you tried
to use
what the challenges are and then where
you guys are now yeah it's it's
interesting the entire industry
buckets everything cannabis related into
an mrb a marijuana marijuana-related
business
despite the fact that cbd products are
federally legal so they just
you see just started interrupting real
quick but you see marijuana it's like
literally the cops are like involved
somehow
like marijuana related business they're
like oh bad people marijuana right right
yeah
yeah so
um so when i started i was literally
having to get on the phone with people
that sounded like car salesmen that they
were e-merchant brokers
because i couldn't use if you're
building on shopify like you're a normal
d2c company which
we have part d to see uh distribution
i can't use stripe which is shopify's
preferred payment
so shopify will let you operate if you
are a you have to get approved
a weed related business we'll go with
wrb okay
weed related business i'm not a cop i'm
not a cop right weed related business
but stripe the payment processor will
not process payments for
these mrbs exactly okay so we then had
to
find out what's our options so we went
through
square but you they have a very very
small
allowance of cbd companies extreme we're
vc-backed company so we were able to get
into their beta program but then you
have to
shopify won't pass directly to square so
now you got to put in a third party
handoff okay and then there's
emergent broker is like what is the e
merchant broker that sounds like a shady
industry
it really is okay what is that it's just
the handoff
between a payment platform okay you use
use
car salesman so that's where i'm getting
the shady it's literally the car
salesman that's like
i'm trying to sell you this car they're
trying to be that middle man
of the shopping cart and the payment
okay which stripe basically killed that
industry
exactly if you can use stripe exactly
makes sense
so when you start doing this were you
able to get up and running at first and
then they quickly shut you down or like
do they not even let you get up and
running because they realize
yeah the m word is part of this business
exactly okay so
and you it's whack-a-mole like i
literally will get down the line of
an sms platform and then they'll be like
oh wait wait wait we just looked at your
website you're cbd sorry we can't we
can't support you and the same with like
fundraising
for text message yeah oh it's probably
cause the word marijuana cops like i'm
telling you
i'll tell you they know that that m word
is gonna pop up they think i'm just like
yeah
so it's that it's fundraising too like
i've learned that i am just super
transparent up front it's like we
are a cbd company we're helping you know
women
but if i tried doing the like female
wellness angle
they find out and then i've gone down
this path
and now i have to come back and find new
solutions so because there's certain
banks and other types of financial
institutions that
uh will make it very difficult for
people to invest as well not only
for you to process payments but
investors et cetera exactly and also
where their money comes from like if
their lps are in the middle east
they i have like the double whammy
because i'm cannabis and sexual health
which in the vc world sexual health was
just made a category so that you could
actually
size the market and have comps that was
just three years ago
and so a lot of lps that are coming from
different parts of the world
if they're in that fund i i can't even
talk
to them dumb question middle eastern lps
religious or they just don't like sex or
what's going on there
or combination i think it's still
patriarchal societies
okay so not necessarily directly a
religious thing
as much as it is like a societal and
cultural thing
okay and they're putting pressure or
having the doctor they have
vice clauses got it okay literally
they're like yep yeah okay
so you've raised capital how much uh to
date 2.5
all right 2.5 million dollars and the
whole idea is you're gonna take uh what
right now is three products the
sex sleep and stress all s's very uh
very good alliteration there
and you basically use cbd in these
products in the gummies
and you go and you saw it on the
internet except for there's one twist
yeah i'm fascinated by this and the
first time i heard this as i'm assuming
most investors they go
this is either shady or
this is genius and like i don't know how
to underwrite it
okay but what you basically do is you
have uh
like tupperware style distribution
i didn't understand this until literally
before the podcast i'm cheating now
part of this is because you're getting
shut down by the payment processors
and we're getting shut down by facebook
okay explain that
you cannot so we are ingestibles
many cbd companies ingestible means i
can literally put it inside your body
yep
many cbd cbd companies will launch a
topical mean like a cream or something
and then they'll run paid ads for that
and that's cool if that's cool exactly
all right but since i'm
fully focused on efficacy i i wanted
just ingestibles
facebook will not let me run any paid
ads
because we're ingestibles so you can
have a facebook page
you can have a personal profile but you
can't run paid ads right
okay why is zuck not like weed
is marijuana he's a cop like love you
love you sorry just kidding but like i
mean what's up with that
yeah so cbd anything that goes in the
body or is it
specifically targeting weed cbd slash
thc uh yeah anything adjustables oh guys
okay so this isn't specifically this sub
sector of ingestibles is anything that
you put inside your body
they aren't cool with right okay now i
get your question yeah it's just cbd
adjustable
okay obviously you can't do thc because
that's not federally legal you can't run
paid ads to teach thc
not allowed federally yeah but cbd
because it's an adjustable
but like there's no tropics there's
other people like
that are running paid out can you do
alcohol paid ads for alcohol
no no okay interesting that changes my
opinion a little bit
if you could do paid ads for alcohol
then i'd be like that kind of is like
hypocritical right if you can't do
payday you can run paid outs for viagra
huh so how can you yeah
but is that persecution is that
prescribed him and hers are not
prescribed
and they have no but don't they oh maybe
not i don't know i don't know enough
about it
uh but i wonder if there's like a
prescription component of it in terms of
if it's prescribed by a doctor then like
it's okay somehow i don't know
no it's the alcohol thing is interesting
yeah maybe we'll get some data on uh on
that before
we like pause the podcast all right so
you can't use facebook ads to get
distribution
yep the payment systems are all
basically screwing you
yeah so then explain this distribution
network i'm
fascinated by the idea of uh innovation
and ingenuity comes out of necessity
which is a you're like the classic case
for this
yeah so i grew up in the midwest small
town all right
everyone in the midwest says that my
town's 800 people that's very small okay
keep going yeah
i think my high school is bigger than
that yeah um
so everyone sold you know mary kay
roden and field you name it right those
are mlms
dumb question what are those so an
mlm no no mary kay makeup
and rodent fields skin care and gotta
got it like they're brands
exactly so and tupperware is a good
example right so what is an mlm
multi-level marketing
meaning you make more money as you
recruit people below you and it's the
reason why it's called a pyramid scheme
right there's somebody at the top who
started recruited their friends
those people had to recruit more friends
and what happens is the person at the
top gets a percentage
of each of the people under them so the
person at the top is making a ton of
money
people at the bottom are making nothing
is this illegal
yes it is illegal it is but there are
loopholes and there are still
tons of mlms out there and they're
predatory on low socioeconomic
households okay because less than one
percent of women in
mlms make money what is the
loopholes that people expose
it's i think in how they register okay
in
in their like corp docs et cetera
there's some sort of legal
finagling they do so it's not so much
the operational components it's more of
the legal component
exactly all right i always think of mlms
as uh
when bill ackman went after uh whatever
the uh the shake company is yes
yeah herbalife or something or life yeah
yeah uh i watched the documentary i'm
hip you know
but uh like that's basically one of his
arguments right and i've
zero understanding of like what's real
what's not in the documentary all the
stuff
but the whole idea was like he was
saying hey this is
basically taking advantage of the lowest
socioeconomic classes
exactly and like i don't know
documentaries seem that way but who
knows right
so i studied mlms because i'm from the
midwest lots of people sell them i'm
like
what is drawing women to these things
and it
came down to really two key components
they wanted to be a part of something
that was like a brand and a mission that
they stood for
and they wanted to make money and they
were being sold this idea of making
money so what wasn't working
that what actually makes them predatory
huge upfront costs and monthly minimums
you have to buy
500 worth of product every single month
whether you sell it or not they don't
care
right um and then the recruiting part
which feels disgusting it's like join my
team
come over and then you start to like
lose friends it's very alienating so
if you break it down to what the core
component is women have
influence and they talk about products
to their friends i was walking around
the design district yesterday and
someone was like
oh my god i love your sandals where'd
you get them i was like oh they're
soothies like
here's the link to instagram whatever
that's how we find out about cool brands
because you
talk to your friends so if we boil that
down
that's my entire distribution strategy i
have women who try the product
if it helps them they get an affiliate
link they talk to their friends they
host parties
they want to talk about these things
that have been by society stigmatized
like we aren't allowed to talk about sex
it's
taboo and then we're also
compartmentalized it's like oh you have
your
your friend group that you talk about
parenting with your friend group that
you talk about careers with and then you
have like your close friends you talk
about sex with
we're creating a brand that kind of
realizes that women are multi-hyphenates
and that what was that word
multi-hyphenate like what is that like
you can be a mom you can have sex
you can like and um moms don't have sex
keep going
how did we become mom i don't know i
don't know i don't know keep going
please keep going
and and tapping into love you mom
hi mom um and tapping into the fact that
we're influential with
our friends and and so that 65 of our
sales comes from what we call wise women
and they are
not only coming to us for these products
that are helping them but then we have
this entire education and community
that is teaching them so as they're
making money so
average woman makes about a hundred
dollars a month rather than being like
an mlm that's like now you can go to
target or go buy more starbucks or
whatever
we're like you want to learn about
bitcoin let's talk about
cryptocurrency what is it let's talk
about blockchain
et cetera and so they're they feel a
safe space to ask all the questions and
that's my end goal is to get
more than whatever it's like 10 of women
hold you know wallets so
all right so hold on let's go back for a
second uh the difference between
i think i understand this mlm and what
you're doing
is in the mlm if i'm participating
my goal is not to sell products my goal
is to sell people to become a
person and then we go sell products but
really i don't want them to sell
products i want them to go recruit more
people
and it's basically like i just built an
army of mlm folks i don't know if
anything ever gets sold but like i have
a bunch of people underneath well they
all have
monthly minimums so they have to keep
buying the product so it doesn't matter
if they sell that product
they're responsible for that monthly
minimum got it and that's like probably
a lot of money
that's most of their sales got it okay
what you're doing is you're saying
don't go recruit anybody instead here's
an affiliate link
no different than if i went and a
company gave me an affiliate link and i
tweeted it exactly
versus if i said hey five friends come
over and then like i'm gonna like
tap on the phone for you yeah buy this
[ __ ] exactly
okay and so really
the biggest difference is the
affiliate model which is what you're
doing but it's trying to use human
connections friendships et cetera and
create like a safe space of community
whatever
okay once they
buy the product is it a one-time
purchase or is it a subscription
purchase
so we literally just launched
subscriptions this week so people can
so you can do either one exactly i have
multiple friends
the reason why i know a little bit about
this uh weed stuff
is not marijuana no no weed uh
is i have multiple friends who have
taken the gummies and uh
people that folks on twitter will know
um
and they swear by them yeah and like one
of my friends is very very health
conscious to the point where like one
time i had to ask him i was like
i think i noticed like you don't drink
either and he was like
no and i was like you don't eat carbs
really and he was like
not really and then i was like okay well
what about this weed thing
and he was like oh it's very healthy and
he explained it to me and it was the
whole idea of like the melatonin the cbd
may help him go to sleep
and so what i'm fascinated by is if
you're getting
shut down by let's just call it and this
is an over generalized term but
big tech right whether it's facebook not
allowing you to do payments
stripe not allow or i'm sorry facebook
not allowing you to do paid advertising
stripe not allowing you to do payments
whatever
you almost have to recreate this model
and so
it sounds like you're using some like
sketchy people to help you put together
the
uh payment infrastructure not because
you want to use them but you're being
forced to use them as like brokers and
stuff uh which we'll get to in a second
but then also from a distribution
standpoint you've almost like
created this whole new different
different distribution plan
some of it is like old atomic affiliate
model as old as time exactly it's just
that you're now infusing education
community etc together
and it seems to be working yeah yeah why
don't why doesn't everybody do this
i get dms all the time from d to c
founders being like
how do you do this how are you managing
them and so we see an opportunity there
as well because they're how are you
managing them
there are some very bootleg like
different software is that
we you duct tape together and you have
to have really smart devs to make sure
that everything passes through because
now
it's not just like affiliate link
tracking through one payment platform
as a reminder i had to like put that
middleman in so that affiliate
conversion has to track through like
three different platforms so why don't
you just take dollars
like cash hard cash just be like hey
just paying cash i mean that's why have
you ever gone to a dispensary that's
like
yeah most the old school dispensaries
were like just
cash because of that reason i was joking
when i said that but like that actually
makes a lot of sense
because literally they couldn't do any
payment processing so it was cash only
exactly
man and no wonder everyone was like oh
these are like bad people because
they're only doing cash but it's like no
you're forcing us
you're forcing us yeah okay so why don't
you do cash
because we're digital like we want to
make sure that it it's scalable
and doesn't feel shady and who's using
cash like women aren't walking around
with like
like sally down the street she's just
got like a safe full of cash
and she's like i got some sex coming so
you got a hundred the cat the cops show
up and they're like hey where's those
marijuana parties going on
this is just cbd but we just want to
make it really really shady
all right so you're doing digital
payments uh and people can use credit
card debit card what all the normal
stuff right
but the affiliate link is the key to
this whole thing because that's how you
ensure that whoever
uh recruits their friends as buyers
not as not anything else right uh and
basically
all the affiliate link yep if you can
track that all the way through then
you're able to pay them
exactly how do you do the split like how
much do you guys take first how much do
they get paid
they get a high like it's 20 to 25
affiliate commission which is higher
than
that's really most affiliates because
that's the money that i would have to
pay google and facebook
to acquire sales so i just
redid my entire model to say i'm not
giving a dollar to google and facebook
that is going to women who are
supporting this mission
got it so basically uh
thinking all the venture capitalists who
hate the fact that you know 20 to
80 cents off of the dollars that they
their companies fundraise go to google
and facebook is basically just a tax on
the startup industry
through paid marketing you're not saying
well why don't we just give it to the
actual people who need it
and it's a higher roi because those
people are also content creators
i get so much more out of them they'll
content create they
they want like our seed round
announcement like got so much
amplification just from all the wise
women i have 500 women who are
500 yeah that are doing the parties yeah
there are weed parties happening in this
country that y'all don't know about let
me tell you about these weed parties
sally's got a lot of friends they ain't
got no cash
but they got weed all right so wait what
like how does this happen
i'm a woman and i see this and i'm like
i need to
i want to participate yeah uh i want to
make money i have friends they want
weeds they want to learn about bitcoin
like all the things
as much as i'm joking around right they
they want these products yeah
i want it i think my friends want it i
contact you like through the website or
like
like walk me through how does somebody
become a wise woman yeah they literally
go to this website they go through the
flow
they we approve them they get an
affiliate link and then they go through
a full
like education about what is cbd
exactly right we have a full slack
channel that all of our wise women are
in
and the cool thing that was the most
surprising thing since launch we've been
live for six months i was like okay
we'll see if women want to talk about
these products et cetera what i didn't
realize is this community that was
happening kind of behind
the social media wall i realized that
there's a lot of things that twitter
can't do for women where a lot of women
don't want to talk about their sex lives
in the public eye but they want to talk
about it in a group of people that can
support them etc
so this idea of a community that they
can reach out to but then
what i'm learning because i'm a marketer
i've been marketer for 15 years a lot of
marketers have come in
they're teaching the women how to create
awesome content it's like
i don't understand how to make a tick
tock somebody will jump in and be like
okay here's what you do you film it this
way and they'll create a video etc
and so they're teaching women life
skills
that are like marketing is life skills
like i was just going to say you got to
say marketing's a life skill because
people will persecute you on the
internet if you say tick tock is a life
skill
even though tic tac is not a large scope
but it's well yeah maybe if
you could make money on it then hey it's
right true it's a career right whatever
um marketing is a life skill for sure
everything is marketing or sales uh and
sometimes both um
when they come in do you see
anything interesting in the data so you
have 500 women that are holding the
uh kind of parties it's not just parties
i'm assuming they're also doing other
things because it's just an affiliate
link
social media etc hey guys what's going
on before we continue with this awesome
episode i want to quickly talk about our
sponsor kraken
for the last 10 years kraken has built
one of the best platforms to buy and
sell cryptocurrencies online
they've got a brand new mobile app the
kraken app today you can go on and buy
bitcoin
or up to 60 of the most popular
cryptocurrencies in the world
and you can do that on the go 24 7.
all you have to do is simply download
the app connect your bank account
and you can get started investing with
as little as 10
it only takes a minute to get started
with the new kraken app you'll have your
portfolio
in your pocket you can track your
portfolio see who the winners and losers
are every day
track your favorite project or just
simply look at the trading volume for
your favorite assets
it has all the features you need without
any of the complexity
it's simply the best place to buy and
sell cryptocurrencies
so go to kraken.com bang bang to learn
more
or go to your favorite app store and
simply search the word kraken and you
can download the mobile app there
crackit's been a long time supporter of
this show so to say thanks it would mean
the world to me if you would go and
download their new mobile app
all right let's get back into this
episode i hope you're enjoying this one
do you see anything that
gives you a inclination as to who will
be more successful than
somebody else like is it a certain
geography is it household income is it a
certain education level
is it like you have a lot of followers
on the internet like what do you see
it's intention okay interesting what
does that mean someone who's dedicated
in talking about it regularly i mean
it's just like ad impressions you
need to see an ad like six to seven
times really like authenticity
yeah right and so if you that's what
we're looking for like when we look
think about influencer programs right
it doesn't matter how many followers
somebody has it's
how much engagement and what kind of
engagement are people
asking like oh my gosh where did you get
this thing are they
truly truly invested and feel that
emotional connection to the
the creator and that's the core
component of all the wise women it's
like
if they actually tried the products and
they slept better like your friend
and he's like i i sleep so much better
with this thing
you're now more inclined to try it right
and so it's first
step one is just letting them try the
products
seeing how they feel and when they get a
better night's sleep where they were
able to handle their anxiety or their
kids were being crazy and they
felt better during that they talk
authentically about that
and then it leads to sales it doesn't
feel like it's a hashtag
ad sponsored post can men
join yeah we have wise men is that
allowed yeah we have wise men yeah
all right and they hold parties too
they're i maybe maybe i don't know i
don't know what's happening with the
wise men um they they're tweeting about
it they're
telling they're posting on instagram and
they're selling
like a lot a lot do men or women sell
more
probably women we just have we reach
more women yeah yeah
like on average men are buying the
product
it's like degree deodorant their home
marketing campaign was like
strong enough for a woman made for a man
or
is like strong enough for man made for a
woman yeah yeah
huh and so i guess part of this then
becomes you have to have the right
products
right you have the right branding and
the distribution becomes really
interesting
why not have people pay in bitcoin until
i completely remove
the cause basically what you're talking
about here is like this is the crux of
what bitcoin is
it's unsensible money nobody can tell
you you're not allowed to accept bitcoin
for payment
because of what company you are who you
are if it was
what religion or nobody can tell you
what to do you want to accept it you can
accept it
i don't disagree with you i think step
one is under
hitting my demographic which is
millennial women helping them
understand what it is yeah because they
can't buy it if they don't even know it
or trust it
so step one is we're doing all this
education around what is bitcoin was the
future of currency
and then giving them the option hey
you made a hundred dollars this month
one in fiat
one in bitcoin yep so that's step one to
me because it's almost like what you're
really doing
is you're helping people generate income
and then once they get the income you're
trying to help educate them in terms of
uh like financial empowerment exactly
right
yeah it's fascinating because really you
could imagine that corporations or
employers if they were sensical people
they would basically be
empowering folks through education yeah
huh all right and then once people
understand
bitcoin then they could pay in the
future whatever exactly
it blows my mind that bitcoin and cbd
thc et cetera haven't all
right well they're in the same bucket
because from a societal standpoint
they're still kind of fringe type things
but people who live on the fringe people
who are forward thinking people who
who are comfortable with like the the
highest degrees of innovation
i think both of those things are like
no-brainers like yeah of course the
government's gonna
make you know marijuana legal right
right versus
uh bitcoin like yeah of course that's
gonna be a thing in the future yeah it's
almost like the
the legacy system they're the ones who
don't get it yet exactly
huh okay what's next
what's next is continuing to grow the
brand that's key for
more weed parties more wheat parties not
wheat
cbd um and honestly looking at this
technical infrastructure and
getting ahead of it because they're
like i said i get a ton of inbound
asking like how do you manage
the future of d2c is going to be a
little bit more
shifting from big tech to the people who
are your ambassadors community community
has been a buzzword in the marketing
world for like the past two years like
how do you build
authentic community if you're actually
doing that then how do you activate them
as sales people
as more and more brands do that there's
not good software out there and so how
do we
really kind of stay ahead of that this
is a wild idea and i just had it so i
could be completely
okay hit me the wise women are basically
retail locations
yeah it's the future yeah you just built
a retail chain it just happens to be
their mobile
brick and mortar and they literally do
it inside their living room
future of brick and mortar is humans
yeah i'm sure that the woke crowd really
gets mad when you say that because
they're like you know we're
humans and like we have feelings uh but
with all that said
uh yeah like that's basically what
happened they're like they're the store
manager yeah of your store in wherever
illinois
and they just don't have a place they go
to work they just invite all of the
customers into their
living room yeah our company is named
after brownie wise who created the
tupperware party
who brownie wise she's the woman who
created the tupperware
that's her first name brownie yeah for
some reason that makes a lot of sense
that you would be the tupperware party
creator and your first name would be
brownie yeah what is her story
she wanted to empower women after the
war to make money in their households so
created this idea of
selling tupperware from your home earl
tupper who is the creator of the storage
thing when brownie asked her asked him
for a raise an executive position etc he
ended up firing her because she had
already
made this movement he sold the company
three months later and she got nothing
and she had created the idea of the
tupperware parties yeah the idea that
women have influence over their friends
yeah i mean that's like a no-brainer
what
right isn't it known i thought that was
like not before the tupperware party not
from like a
commerce perspective yeah but but isn't
it uh is the statistic
that women control the household
spending like there's all the kind of
data that suggests like if you basically
convince the mother
of the household yep game over yep
and that's why the two most important
demographics if you're building a
technology company to get into
is uh teen like
teenage to like young 20s females
who then share talk whatever it's not
physical products like hey
you said like somebody actually ate your
sandals it's did you see this new app
did you whatever like a very
collaborative nature and
kind of recommendation and then moms and
the moms like it's like actually the
guys are the second
all my friends i i ask them like what
laundry detergent do you use
and did is it the one your mom used is
it yeah
because their mom uses so they use it
yeah what else is there where like
there's a lineage of if your mom used it
you use it i'm sure that there's a ton
that's a good question
yeah like i wonder if like deodorant or
toothpaste or what like
toothpaste would be a good one like you
just still use whatever yeah
whatever your mom grabbed off the shelf
that's crazy do you use the same
toothpaste that your mom bought
i honestly i don't know what my mom ever
bought
uh the thing that i always go back to is
uh the best thing my mother ever did
um was at the age of maybe
i don't know probably the age of 14 13
my brothers and i all when we hit that
age we knew how to do
our own laundry and that's like my mom's
big thing was like you have to do your
own logic
but here was the thing was uh the
problem
that you don't understand is if you have
five boys and you've taught them how to
do your laundry that sounds like a great
idea
then they want to do their laundry every
day because that's my favorite shirt and
i need to wear it tomorrow
and so literally they know how to use
the machine so they just go put the sh
one
shirt in the water bill's so then you
have to start to be
come up with rules like hey there's only
so many times
it's like building a startup honestly
it's like you don't know what you don't
know until you make a decision you're
like okay now i need slis around this
stuff
and then of course if your sons are all
able to use the laundry room
at free will even within the rules
fist fights just randomly break out like
your brother walks down the stairs and
next he knows you're just
fighting and your mom breaks it up he's
like what are you guys doing and you're
like he's wearing my socks
and she's like how do you know that
you're socks
and you're like cause they're black
she's like but he has black socks
and not those black socks oh my gosh
like that is literally
what happened and then of course you get
smart you say okay well let's all buy
different pairs of socks like we all
know whatever
then shorts then that's my t-shirt and
oh but that one
inside the tag i wrote my name there is
no tag in this one you cut out the tag
like let's fight
oh my gosh i wonder if you guys still
wear the same color socks that you
bought us like a kid
no we have a running joke we all just
wear black t-shirts that's it okay and
so now as
uh semi-adults uh
it still would be confusing uh but we
have we have several homes right now
yeah
separate washing machines has solved
this problem but
if you guys go on trips how how old do
you have to be to use the
cbd we say 21. 21. that's the
thing and so does this infiltrate into
colleges
yeah so we do have we we've never
targeted that demographic
yet just because we believe that again
moms have a lot of influence and we
wanted
we started this in the pandemic like i
raised two rounds in the pandemic
because i saw all of my mom friends
turning to alcohol
because of stress yep and i wanted to
give them an alternative that they could
trust
because the alcohol as we know like it
doesn't
serve you affects your sleep affects
your head gut connection et cetera and
anxiety
so we started with that but yes 100
could go to colleges
yeah it's uh it's really interesting
when you start to think of all the
groups where they're already like
very high degree of connections high
trust and then
uh kind of built-in recommendations
whatever like i remember
uh in college uh there's a group of
friends of mine
uh if anyone got into anything like hey
man these shoes are really comfortable
it was like bam yeah literally everyone
has so a demographic we're we're talking
to now
is hair stylist because you sit in that
chair as a woman
for like three hours and you talk about
everything
really yeah man see i don't think guys
do that i don't think guys really talk
to the barbers
no they talk to each other they don't
like the barbers and not so much okay
it also depends what type of barbershop
you go to okay but hairstylist
you're in the chair for a while and so
they we have a couple of people who are
like
i'm just going to start selling it to my
clients because they're stressed they're
telling us how stressed they are
and they're going to make money again
i don't know what i don't know so this
is a wild question but
women go to the hair stylist sit in the
chair then tell a random woman that they
don't really know like yeah i'm super
stressed and like just like start
sharing your hairstyle is not a random
person
okay i didn't understand that got it you
because you go to the same one every
time
yeah oh yeah guys don't do that i just
caught my own yeah like whatever
no that person knows your like
intricacies of your life
really yeah because you go there like if
you're like me and blonde and
you're going like every eight weeks and
so you just see them over and over and
over and over again
and then you trust them because they you
trust them with your hair so like if
they tell you to
get ingestibles then like you're
whatever yeah yes
so there's lots of things it's all about
exactly but it's all about that trust
factor like
who do you confide in for
recommendations and we are
tapping into those network effects yeah
are there other groups that you're
that you think could be interesting oh
we've been talking about priest
i feel like the priest could just be
like here ye
it's really funny because i do refer to
religion a lot of like
how do you assemble a cult-like
mentality and it's like
study religion no literally if the
priest went up in front and did this
sermon it was like by the way get some
cbd
like they would all go buy it yeah they
look they're he's already like put 10 of
your income in this basket then
people just fork it over like as if like
i don't know they'd have no clue where
the money goes but they're just like
here's some cash
yeah and then they're like eat this
flesh and blood and
yeah but even that's like our as part of
their religion piece but like
i've always been fascinated since i was
a little kid and they would pass that
basket around a catholic church
and people would just put cash in and
then it would go to a random person
and i used to always be i know they're
taking it like i don't know who that is
but like
like some kid like you're telling me
that kid's carrying around a couple
hundred dollars in a basket he didn't
take a dollar
maybe he didn't i don't know but like to
me
inside of the church and this is we've
seen the bad side right like obviously
there's been all the the negative stuff
uh um with priests and in the catholic
church or whatever
but like there's just this element of
like once you got inside those
walls of a church i don't want to say
all rational thought left or like like
uh independent thought
but there was this sense of like i trust
the people here i trust the message i
trust whatever and like
if priests told people to go get cbd i
guarantee they'd go get it
potentially not not as excited about i'm
not going after priests don't think
they'd be aligned with my core mission
no longer the house of jesus is the
house of wise
yeah that's a different house bomb like
very different house than we're going
after
all right what other groups um we think
a lot about massage like
where you go to get massages i think
that same dynamic as the hairdresser
well and also like where you're going to
relax i think yoga studios etc where you
actually are trying to like
get in touch with your body and feel
your body so and so basically if people
go ahead and they buy the product
at the yoga studio the yoga suits make
an additional income we focus on this
the teachers like someone who's an
independent they're they
are a yoga instructor etc we focus on
the individuals
first because that's our distribution
strategy uh i didn't understand this but
uh
my amazing loving wife
has a a person but a a
instructor person oh yeah uh who she
used to go to the classes
and uh i don't really know what goes on
there but she comes back says like it
was a good workout
okay um and then during the pandemic
the classes moved on zoom yeah and i
made a mistake at one time
walking into the room while this was all
going on and
uh fascinating they're all like talking
to each other
like i i didn't really understand it but
they were like what kind of work work
out
oh it's like a like no like with like
weights or whatever
like whatever and she's like leading it
and there's like yeah music playing or
whatever and she's like kind of like
yelling into her computer and then it's
like going to everyone else's room
but i was just like oh my god like this
is church
yeah like literally if she was like
everyone go by cbd right now they'd all
just run and go down 100
if you look at like the numbers of
religion and how it's going down
but then like new industries are going
up it's replacing
people want a sense of belonging and
this like cult like mentality of being a
part of something and i think fitness
kind of took over in the last couple
years what's your take on astrology
this is real every time mercury's in
retrograde i swear
something happens but literally i don't
know what that means that was like
another sign that was like another
language
literally like everyone go dating
nowadays it's like
should we pair on cosign and i'm like
what is that it's an app that tells you
if you're compatible
i'm out so i don't know
i don't know i've seen people in the
tech community be like this is all
garbage like it's literally a scam a
fraud whatever
and then i've literally seen them also
at the same time defend religion
and also at the same time defend any
sort of group dynamic that
seems to be like astrology so i view
astrology
as it's a mechanism to be able to talk
about yourself
in a way that lets others learn about
you
and so kind of like enneagram or myers
breaks or whatever it's like oh
you're an enfj so like how do you react
in this situation
and it allows you a framework to talk
about it's like oh i'm a libra that
means i'm
care about balance and so then i talk
about how i achieve balance in my life
i think all of those things are just
like rooted in self-awareness and
wanting to get
people to connect with you on a deeper
level okay
so i buy all that for the most part uh
what is your
um birthday thing what's my sign
yeah yeah that's what that's what i'm
supposed to say sorry jesus
i'm embarrassing myself right now okay
uh is
what what does libra mean i cannot
believe somehow i am talking about
i feel like we need to look up yourself
oh no i know what mine is okay
i'm positive what mine is okay and uh
but go ahead
you explain first and then i'll tell you
what mine is i'm a libra which means
well and also there's lots of different
ways you can say i'm a libra
and libras care about justice balance
and and doing right and what does that
mean like does do people who are not
libras care about
doing right is everyone else a scumbag
just your i don't know because i don't
know if i fully believe in it but i
think it's a way to talk about like
okay i believe in justice and balance
and here's how i approach it but
what are you uh i'm a gemini and
i have no clue what that means otherwise
if i was an astrology girl i'd be like
yeah
i knew that i i knew you were no here's
the best part i have no clue what a
gemini means except for polina one day
goes do you know who else is a gemini
and i was like who
kanye west donald trump elon musk like
she went this whole list and i was like
oh my god i don't want to be a gemini
like the list is absurd so my my brother
who you met
my youngest brother is also a gemini
okay and uh we're pretty similar or
whatever
but i'd like to think that just because
we're cool not because of some
star [ __ ] on them okay after this
we're doing co-star msc but
but my whole thing is just uh the
astrology
thing is very similar to religion to me
which is also very similar to
uh school where there's a trust which
seems like a lot similar to like what
you're doing right which is just like
if you get people together and they
trust each other and they
uh put value in the recommendations that
they make
what's the difference between saying hey
you're born in this month let me
do or maybe tarot cards are different
okay whatever same thing it's all the
same
you know whatever oh now you're going to
have this outcome in life
and if you start to think that like same
thing with
hey do you want to get better sleep it's
just yeah once a physical product
actually has science behind it and the
other is like you know woo
stuff i disagree i think yes
i why one is who's in control
okay what does that mean i want women to
feel in the driver's seat of their lives
because in the astrology world they're
just like whatever mercury you've
what is mercury you keep saying that
there's a phrase
mercury in retrograde which means that
that sounds like a rap song
go ahead and it means like technology
will always like
okay can i say [ __ ] but like um it will
just be like [ __ ] up for
the entire week that mercury is mercury
in retrograde
i'm just gonna start dropping that on
the podcast randomly to people like
mercury and retrograde
no no that would be too intelligent i'm
just gonna just randomly say it like the
next podcast i record like yeah mercury
in retrograde
see if the next person knows what you're
talking about though the next person
actually probably will because i know
exactly who's coming in next but go
ahead
um but so for me i want women to feel
empowered and in control astrology
religion is all relinquishing control to
another power another thing
i want i'm saying i need help with my
libido
i'm going to do something about it god
it's an action oriented versus a
reaction
exactly if i tweet mercury in retrograde
what do we think happens
people will say not for another three
days or something wait what
they'll tell you when it's gonna happen
oh it's like a time event
yeah it happens how do i measure when
it's going to happen
we could google it right now but like
how does google know
like is it like like is it something to
do with the sun or something to do with
mercury
like the planet yes oh my god get out of
here
there's a thousand planets there's
nothing why is mercury why isn't it
pluto in retrograde
i don't know listen
for all of you listening at home who are
watching this right now the state of
disbelief on my face
says everything there's people who
literally
are gonna in three days i think the
life's changed because mercury's in
retrograde
i don't know what that means but it
sounds cool some of us are saying it now
okay where can people go find house
supplies on the internet
um housewives.com houseofwise.com
they can pay with cash credit card or
debit cards
yes it all works no one can shut you
down as of right now not right now we're
gonna get everybody on bitcoin
eventually yeah
and then if they want to sign up to be a
wise woman or man but wise woman then
they can go
housewife.com they'll they'll see
they're all right okay three questions
and then you could ask me one to finish
up what's the most important book you've
ever read
oh waking up
sam harris what's that about
spirituality
mindfulness intention no mercury in
retrograde
retrograde um just
living life presently and and
actually being in the moment that's why
it's called waking ups i i really like
sam harris
um so yeah stick with that all right
second question eight sleep
uh i sleep on it i love it i super cold
eight nine hours a night uh i'm like
religious like they've converted me to
the sleep religion
uh what is your sleep schedule i go to
bed every night at 9 30
9 30 okay and i'm a 5 am or 5 a.m
i'm not doing public math seven and a
half hours give or take
yeah and what time do your kids wake up
seven oh so you have like time
yeah that's when i like without any kids
all right
uh third question is aliens now we're
talking about mercury and retrograde
yeah
uh by the way planet is gonna love the
fact that i don't know what that is but
i keep saying it
um i might text her that when we get
done and not say anything else
uh do you believe in aliens yeah why
there's different universes and solar
systems out there why would we believe
that we're the only
living being have you seen an alien
working release ufo data but ufos aren't
aliens
i have never seen an alien all right i
neither have i
i think they are out there i think they
don't but i just don't uh i haven't seen
all right
one question you have for me
what is one belief that you've had in
the beginning of your podcast journey
that has been changed
because of guessing i don't change my
mind that would be blasphemous
um what's one
thing that i believe that i've changed
my mind on
i don't know i'd have to think about
this to have a good answer um
i would say that
it's not sometimes i've changed my mind
maybe as much as
uh i've developed a deeper appreciation
for aspects of the world
that i think people kind of like
intuitively
know is bad but until you talk to an
expert in that space you understand how
bad it is so
criminal justice reform yeah oh yeah
there's people who are locked up
right like that probably shouldn't be
that's like the initial kind of
elementary analysis of the situation
yeah then you go learn about it you're
like
that is really really screwed up we're
talking about cannabis like 40 000
people are still
in jail for something that states are
making millions of dollars doing the
exact same thing
oh they get put in a cage for a plan
it's nuts it's absolutely nuts
uh so i think that's probably the
biggest thing is just like the
intellectual curiosity that it like
curates of like
hey when you hear about something that's
like interesting if you go dig deeper
it's gonna be ten times you know uh
bigger than you thought that's both for
like innovation and like technology
but also for like societal positive or
negative things
so i think like just like that's my
favorite part of the podcast it's just
like it pushes you to like keep learning
yeah all right houseofwise.com you can
sign up
you can buy you can do all kinds of
stuff all right where what is your
twitter account
amanda m gets g-o-e-t-z all right
go x is i how i pronounce it but okay
okay
all right thanks so much thanks mom